a las puertas del atacama el desierto
más seco del mundo el valle de elqui
practica la agricultura intensiva estas
frutas se exportan en el mundo entero
hace 20 años se construyó esta represa
para irrigar esta zona árida su gerente
nos abrió sus puertas excepcionalmente
bajo de la represa a si la zona que
tiene el agua tomamos el agua acá 20.000
hectáreas de plantaciones dependen de
ella en chile el agua es un bien privado
que responde a la ley del mercado desde
1981 cuando de esta pantalla podemos ver
el caudal que está ingresando en este
minuto para el riego
los agricultores compran acciones de
agua aquí cuestan unos 11 mil 700
dólares durante la sequía su cotización
puede dispararse
gracias a esta represa en esta región la
oferta es estable pero no ocurre lo
mismo en todas partes
no hay un mercado del agua hay una
especulación como a lo mejor pasa en
otros lados la quinta región es un
sistema y si invito ha sido difícil la
cosa pero hoy no tienen obras de
acumulación desde hace tanto tiempo como
nosotros a 500 kilómetros al sur se
encuentra petorca y sus inmensas
plantaciones de aguacate es un nombre
rodrigo mundaka denuncia desde hace más
de 10 años estas consecuencias
devastadoras
mira hacia el fondo son plantaciones de
palta este bloque a este profesor de
agronomía lo amenazan constantemente
debido a su constante lucha esta imagen
que lo muestra con un tiro en la cabeza
fue publicada masivamente en las redes
sociales en octubre de 2019
aquí había aquí hace dos año atrás
todavía había agua aquí
el agua es bombeada en las capas
freáticas a más de 60 metros de
profundidad es almacenada en este
reservorio a cielo abierto
el modelo privado del agua se encuentra
consagrado en la constitución política
del 80 y por tanto el aguachile una
mercancía que se compra que se vende que
esa vianda que es además hipotecable e
incluso heredable en esta región
golpeada por la sequía toda el agua es
acaparada por los productores de
aguacates pero ninguno de estos grandes
propietarios deseo abrir sus puertas el
agua es un tema sensible
negativa el tema si piensa en chile
esta fruta constituye sin embargo la
riqueza económica chilena en 2019 batió
todos los récords este mercado
representa más de 352 millones de
dólares las tres cuartas partes de la
producción es para la exportación europa
asia norteamérica pero los pequeños
productores aprovechan poco esta
bendición en estas tierras de su familia
aquiles cultiva 300 árboles de aguacate
denunciar las prácticas de los gigantes
del sector un más grande
no exportador de todo eso son los que
consumen mucha agua el aguacate no está
adaptado a este clima semidesértico
porque viene de las regiones tropicales
y necesita enormes cantidades de agua
mil litros para producir un kilogramo es
decir cinco veces más que la producción
de tomates de torta en la quinta región
ahí no le llega a la gente el pequeño
agricultor todo tomado en el agua lo
empieza frente a estos grandes
productores intocables los habitantes
están condenados a vivir al ritmo de los
camiones cisterna barbara y sus dos
hijos tienen derecho a 50 litros de agua
al día y por persona esta es la reserva
no es para consumo bebible pero si puede
ser para lavar las manos para para el
baño
el fin de la privatización del agua es
una de las reivindicaciones del
movimiento social que sacude a chile
desde hace un año ha estado la llave
está cortado
más del 65% de la población reclama un
cambio de constitución como ellos
bárbara cuenta con el referendo de este
25 de octubre para ponerle fin al
sistema ultra liberal
yo espero que haya una nueva
constitución
de que ya no solamente tengan derecho al
culo que vuelva a ser
que no sea un negocio según greenpeace
la escasez de agua afecta a 350 mil
chilenos el mercado del aguacate nunca
antes había estado también sus
exportaciones se duplicaron en 10 años